>> FISHER: All right. So, let's begin. This
session is: Going Social with the YouTube
APIs. I am Jeff Fisher, and this is Johann
Hartmann, we're presenting today. If you can
read this way in the back, we do have a board
you can post questions to. It's tinyurl.com/io-social-youtube.
So while you're pulling that up, I have to
continue this. So, last year I made this big
stint about what the t-shirts meant and I
pointed out how there were ASCII characters
for Google IO, and of course it turned out
that it didn't actually say Google IO, they
say Google KO because one of the dots was
the wrong kind. So, that's the joke if you
don't know for why this guy has a spray can
on the back and really faintly at the end
here you can see KO kind of sprayed on. So
if you haven't caught that yet. That's--that's
a continuation of my disaster last year of
explaining the shirt that was wrong. Okay.
So we all have the moderator up and running.
Okay. Good. You will be able to also ask questions
in person but if you're shy or just don't
like to talk to me. So we're going to do a
little poll in the audience to make sure you
never sleep, I know it's the second day, I'm
pretty tired too. So, who here has used the
YouTube before? Okay. So you're not all asleep,
that's good. So who here has used the YouTube
API before? Ah, good number, good number.
Okay. So how many of you have noticed on YouTube
that we have the social events like what your
friends are doing or what you're doing like
on channel page. Anyone seen that little box?
Okay. Okay, 'cause now we're going to merge
those two and this is very rare. Is anyone
here actually got in those events through
our API yet? Good! You're in the right talk
'cause that's what we're going to talk about.
So, yes, this talk is about, how we're going
to get the social events and make them available
to you as a developer. And we're going to
do this mostly by going through examples,
because examples are better than just a bunch
of slides about XML. And we're going to have--one
example first that's just really basic, you
know, okay, I'm going to retrieve activity
for a user, I'm going to retrieve their friends
activity and I'm going to retrieve some information
about that, and that's all done in PHP. We
also have a second sample. It's a little more
involved which also has a PHP component to
display information but this example goes
a little bit above and beyond, just a simple
one user use case and it lets you figure out
how you can build an app that will actually
scale the support, you know, assign like millions
of users that you want to keep track of all
their YouTube activity on. And that's one
is going to have a Java component to help
us with the whole scaling and speed thing.
Okay. So, why do you care about YouTube activity?
Why are you here? Well, there are some new
things you can do with it. For example, you
can bring these events into existing social
networks, such as, you know, status updates
or stories or what have you. You can bring
some information to social applications, devices,
gadgets, all that good stuff, just exposing
it to your users in another way. There are
lots of aggregators out there. It's very popular
right now. You can also use it obviously to
create a better YouTube search experience.
So, if you know that my friend rated something
five stars, then perhaps you want to recommend
that video to me more highly and the search
results or highlight that somehow because,
you know, that probably more interesting to
me than just a normal video if someone I knew
liked it. And then of course, you can also
educate your app about what a user is doing
on-site. So, if you have a really awesome,
say, Android or iPhone app, you don't really
know what a user does on YouTube when they're
not using your Apps. So, how can you train
that App to respond to those events? Well
that's what these activity feeds are good
for. So, for example, I just rated this five
stars again, we go back to that example, and
I'm out and about, you know, when I have my
little Android device, and you know, I'm not
lying. I actually, do have one. It will be
really useful if I have this really awesome
App for it that already integrates with YouTube.
If it was like, "Hey, here's all the things
you recently rated highly or that you favorited."
I mean, now I guess with cupcake, you can
get your favorites on the YouTube App. But
you know, understand like, you can actually
learn from what user is doing and provide
useful suggestions in your App which is cool.
Okay. So, and I mentioned this is--or maybe
I didn't quite mention it. But we're using
these APIs, called the YouTube data API, and
its very similar to or other Google data APIs,
if you're familiar with them. Speaking of
which, how many people have used one of our
data API spreadsheets. Okay. All they own.
Its okay, you're familiar. Okay. So it's based
Atom Publishing Protocol which, if you're
not familiar what that is, it's a lot of XML.
So, our API is a lot of XML. We're working
to make that better particularly, with doing
more things with Jason (ph). There was a talk
the first day, so if you didn't see that,
you already missed it. But we are going in
that direction. So it's going to be less work
in the future. But for right now, it's XML.
I'm not going to go into too much detail about
the API but you should know it's a version,
so 2 is greater than 1, yeah. Version 2 is
the current version and has also some goodies
like GeoSearch, the most activity stuff we're
talking about today. Version 1 doesn't have
them, so don't use it. The API basically allows
us to look at metadata of all these different
things on YouTube users, channels, videos,
comments, what have you. And also allows us
to programmatically create and manage them
so you now can create videos for a user. You
can favorite a video on behalf of a user.
You can also, of course, upload a video because
what would a YouTube API be if it didn't upload
videos. And then, of course, you also probably
don't want to deal with XML anymore than I
want to deal with XML, so we have a number
of client libraries in your favorite languages.
I actually have a really lightweight thing
I wrote for Ruby, if you're a Rubyist out
there. So, you don't have to go with the XML
directly usually. But, like I said, this is
not a talk about YouTube API, in general.
That was last year. It's on YouTube, if you
want to watch it. But this is a talk about
Activity Feeds that we've done recently. So,
Activity Feeds on YouTube, if you been to
your channel page, you might have seen this
little box, and has stuff that you've recently
done. There's also a similar box on the homepage
you can configure of your friend activities,
all your friends, what they do. And, yes,
there is a giant privacy settings link. Maybe
not super giant but its there, its boxed in
a red for you. So if you'd think all these
stuffs sounds scary, you don't want applications
running about your activity on YouTube you
can go in there and check all these, and none
of what I say in this talk will apply to your
user account anymore, so, there it is. To
give an actual demo of this, and that to prove
that it works, let's have some screen shots,
I'm going to have Johann navigate me through
here. So, here we have spaces. So
we have a recent activity box down there,
like I promised. And I want to go to do something
like go favorite a video.
>> HARTMANN: All right, you want to go...
>> FISHER: Find something clever, I don't
know.
>> HARTMANN: Moving up, yeah.
>> FISHER: Well, that's kind of interesting.
That's not a very good thumbnail 'cause it's
catching people. Okay.
>> HARTMANN: So there it is.
>> FISHER: So you're on favorites, you have
to go back to this, click on like IO demo,
the user name, channel page. So, look! They
actually showed up right away, yeah. Okay.
So, the social stuff actually works. So now
when I show a demo we build that uses our
API to attach this self-same information.
So if you log-in, you do this with a sub,
it's all documented. Basically, we redirect
to a YouTube and we have little crypto key
to make sure that we're from the right domain
name, and we get back here again, now we have
access to the users feeds. And as you can
see, this is the same information that was
in that box but it's on a little site, and
you can, you know, do the embedded player
and whatnot. And also, of course, you can
do a friend activity, you want to click on
that and, you know, you can see what your
friends are doing. But these, of course, have
to be people that you've actually friended
on YouTube. And they also allow you to search
for arbitrary users.
>> How about from your g-mail? Can you search
for g-mail context?
>> FISHER: Okay. So the question was can you
search for g-mail context? And the answer
is no, 'cause unfortunately, you can link
a Google account, a g-mail account, to a YouTube
profile and there might be some crazy auto-suggest
stuff where you can figure out their YouTube
account through that, but you actually, as
of right now, still have to friend them explicitly
on YouTube, like we don't automatically share
your stuff unless you go to YouTube and actually
approve.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FISHER: Yeah, yeah. So gentleman was just
saying that an open social list and useful
stuff about finding most contact and whatnot.
So, the YouTube has--has a lot to work on
in that aspect. We can talk about more about
that later as far as how are we trying to
merge the idea of YouTube accounts and Google
accounts and make these actually useful to
you and not have like a million different
friends lists. That's little bit outside the
scope of activities right now, but it's a
very good point. And part of what we're going
to talk about here is how if you are some
other network that already has contacts, so
if you're in MySpace per se, you already a
friend graph and how can you use that friend
graph and leverage that against YouTube without
actually having some deep integration on YouTube's
part. So here! So we showed you the demos,
so its feeds work, and this is just a URL,
you retrieve, this is a YouTube feeds, API
users. This is documented. I don't expect
you to memorize this right now. So we just
retrieve those events from the API just like
how the box retrieves them from our database,
and there's a very similar URL for a friend
activity, and yes, retrieve your friend's
activity. But as was mentioned, right now
it's limited to YouTube friends which isn't
the most useful thing in the world because
not everyone remembers to friend people on
YouTube if they're already friended on Google
contact or Google talk or Orchid or Hi-5 or
MySpace or whatnot. So, yeah, by getting ahead
of ourselves, the activities that we currently
expose are usually related around videos,
so like the video rated, shared, favorited
events. We also have some user activities.
So, if you add a friend, we'll tell you or
tell you--if you go reflect that, this user
just add a friend, similarly, if they add
the users' description. But what is it look
like? What do you actually seeing in this
XML that I promised you, words entry, that's
how Atom Pub works, every item has its own
entry, and each of them has this ID which
is this big long string. Don't put too much
thought to this, but it will be unique, and
that's what important. We also have updated
element. We shall tell you when this event
took place, so it's, you know, useful for
sorting and organizing. We have a category.
We shall tell you what type of event it is.
This is a user upload, a video upload to user
channel. And we have a short descriptive text
and a title that you can just display verbatim
to the user to, you know, tell them what the
event was, in this case Googledevelopers has
uploaded a video. And then we have the YouTube
username and its own elements, you have to
rejects that out. And, of course, this is
a video upload we'll give you the video ID.
Now we're only giving you the video ID for
this video, we're not giving you the video
title, its rating, its comments, all that
stuff because we don't really want to pollute
this user feed 'cause when talk about a little
bit will be, you know, how you can intelligently
cache that information. And that's all we
have. So, there's a little bit more information
in, for example, the video rating event. We
will actually tell you what rating the user
gave that video. But we'll still are going
to tell you any other video metadata about
it. And of course, if it's a user event, we
will tell you the YouTube user name of the
user they interacted with. Okay. So that's
what this--this is just inside of a giant
XML feed, do not try to read this. I'm not
showing you what I saved you from having to
try to digest. So that was a lot of XML, and
so here are some kittens 'cause I don't like
XML by I do like kittens, and so clear your
minds of all that XML, I don't want to talk
about it too much anymore. So, how did our
sample work? Well, we have our server, it's
host/hostserver, incidentally. And once the
PHP Website, and this PHP Website is going
to go into the cloud, and access YouTube API,
and retrieve the activity information. And
as it does that, it's going to also, like
I said, you don't get the video ID back, so
it has to make addition calls to the API to
populate all the video metadata for each of
those videos, and then we store that video
metadata in a nice caching system like memcached
which I hardly recommend to you--it's not
just because we hired the guy who wrote it
which is a really good system and it's free.
So, we store information in memcache and then
we render all of that to our front-end--which
is written in JQuery which is also awesome
by the way--and we always use a compact JSON
format that we created on the fly to do that
'cause there's a lot of information in our
XML feeds right now that is usually extraneous
to what you want to display on the site. Working
on fixing that in a protocol level but for
right now, you can just kind of dig out what
you need and render it yourself. So, the things
you've got to keep in mind here is you want
to be smart, you know, you want to request
Metadata for each of this items you're getting
back because, you know, telling me that I--that
my friend just favorited video X53976O isn't
very useful to me. And you can retrieve all
that Metadata fortunately by the ID which
we do give you and similarly you can retrieved
all the profile information just by using
YouTube user name. And so, as you're doing
this you can retrieved--you can request only
what you need as you need it which, you know,
sort of lead us into the next part which is
Be Scalable. So, if you have a thousand activity
items but no ones looking at them because
you just pulled them but they're still no
users looking at that yet. You don't really
need to retrieve that Metadata 'cause no ones
going to look at it and, you know, why incur
the penalty of HTP request if you don't have
to. So, what you should do is when you do
make request for your Metadata is you cache
that somewhere, usually one to two hours is
safe and you're trading freshness here for
basically speed and scale and, you know, obviously
if you have been teller talks especially app
engines they'll tell you, hitting a local
cache is a lot cheaper than making an external
HTTP request to our API. And, once again I
do recommend using memcached to do this. And
the last caveat I really want to mention with
this sample is, you know, you got, you want
to be robust. So, there's a lot of different
areas that can happen whenever you're doing
that quick programming that can actually get
interrupted and even like our servers can
temporarily go down or loose your session
or whatever. So, just be graceful when service
errors happen to the API for whatever reason
and provide nice messages to your users. I
mean, this, this is kind of a general good
programming practice but, you know, we ran
into some problems like with people not displaying
useful information because our API is pretty
decent in that like for example, if YouTube
is read only mode--you know that happens a
little bit often for my taste--you can detect
that in the API because we'll give you back
an air message that actually says pretty much,
you know, "YouTube is in read only mode, you
cannot upload right now but you can still
read." And so, you can display something useful
to the user if they're trying to upload a
video and it didn't work for example. But
to talk about the actual PHP Website itself,
I'm going to invite Johann up here since he
wrote a lot of it--he does a lot of work with
our PHP client libraries--so, he's much more
familiar.
>> HARTMANN: So, yes I wanted to start with
just a general question on, how many of you
have actually used one of our client libraries
before? Okay, only a few people. Okay, so,
I'm going to go into it a little bit about
our client libraries work and why we encourage
you to use them as well. But for this application
the PHP Website is a very simple component,
I'm going to talk about this basic front-end
twice. So, this is the first time I'm presenting
you with the overall structure of how we designed
this and then we're going to reuse the same
front-end in a more complex application and
at which point, I would just skip all the
basics because you should already know them.
In general, the kind of things that we need
to do is we need to create sort of a service
object that we use to connect to YouTube.
You'll notice that the word Zen there that's
because our PHP client library is part of
the Zen framework--I don't know how many people
are familiar with the Zen framework but it's
available also as a separate component, a
separate download so you don't need to download
the entire framework. And this is a common
use case for all the other client libraries,
you create some type of service object and
use that to interact with our API's. The other
function obviously is
we want to fetch the activity for a user or
for their friends. We fetch metadata from
YouTube API--so that was in the previous diagram--we
are actually making two requests because we
don't have the metadata yet, we just have
a video ID in the event that Jeff showed.
So, we need to go out again and get the metadata
for the API--for the video. We create our
own JSON feeds inside the application just
for performance and also because we're using
JQuery front-end. So, it's very easy to work
with JSON and JQuery obviously and we're only
interested in displaying specific information
not everything about the video. And then,
you know, we use memcached so, I'm not going
to explain that too well but memcached is
very easy to use in PHP, you just get stuff
out and set things in, very simple. So, what
we're doing here I'm going to explain how
you would use the YouTube service object that
you need to communicate to the API with. This
code is a little bit different because we're
actually using authentication here because
we need you, to get a users friend activity,
you need to make an authenticated request.
So, this is why we're using this Zen_Gdata_Authsub
object here. Authsub--how many of you are
familiar with Authsub authentication? Okay,
only a few. So, I'll explain that a little
bit. So, in general for API's we have two
forms of authentication, there's a client
login based authentication which would be
for desktop apps or you know devices and that's
just simply sending username and password
to our API and getting back a string and then
you use that in the header and you're authenticated.
Authsub is different, it's more sort of a
token or proxy base authentication where your
application basically sends a user over to
YouTube--which is what you've seen when we
demo this--they sign in on YouTube and then
they get set back to your application with
a Token and you store that Token and make
authenticated request, basically on their
behalf. So, what we're doing here in this,
this line of code is we're basically creating
an HTTP client which is going to handle our
communications on the HTTP level and we're
passing in just the session Token that we've
received after the user has sign-in to YouTube.
And then we just set the client in the constructor
of the Zen_Gdata_YouTube object and now we're
basically authenticated. You'll notice here
though that there's some other parameter that
are actually very important for using the
YouTube API's. So, in the second line there
you'll see clientId and developerKey, these
are very important, you need to use a clientId
and a developerKey for any authenticated request
that you're making to YouTube. Of course if
you're just doing a read operation on YouTube,
so you just want to get a feed or something
that doesn't require any authentication--you
don't have to worry about any of these stuff--you
would just use the second line here, so you
just create a new Zen_Gdata_YouTube object
and you go from there. And lastly, you know,
as Jeff mentioned earlier, he have two versions
of API. So, we will set the version to two
so that we can access the activity information.
Here's a slide that shows how this would work
in other client libraries. So, like we've
mentioned we use PHP because I've written
a lot of the extensions and it's very straightforward
for web stuff but you know if you prefer Java.net,
Python, ObjectiveC--I don't have one here--but
it's generally the same. So, you create a
kind of a service object and then you communicate
to our API's with that. And, you know, all
this client libraries worked for other API's
as well so it's all very similar. So, you
can make requests to calendar, YouTube, etc.
Getting activity out is actually very simple
it's just this method, "getActivityForUser"
and you just pass in the user name that you
want activity for --we support up to twenty
username so you can get aggregate activity.
What you get back as an activity feed and
this is another characteristic of our client
libraries is that they abstract a lot of the
XML and transform it into objects for you.
So, that's a lot easier to use, a lot of times,
so in this case we're getting an activity
feed. That feed is going to have entries,
entries are going to have properties so it
mirrors the Xmls structure exactly. To get
friend activities, you know, you just use
the get friend activity for current user method.
The reason why there's no parameter here is
because you can only use this when you're
authenticated and at this point the client
library will know your user so, you don't
have to pass in anything and we'll just get
all your friends activities. Now, getting
video metadata is kind of a multi step process
here because like Jeff mentioned earlier we're
trying to be robust. Or, we want to count
on errors, right, because you could be fetching
video information the same second that somebody
deletes the video on YouTube so you want to
be able to account for this kind of things.
So, we're getting our service--I have abstracted
this in the application in just a simple method
and by the way, all the source code for this
is available. So, if you want to look at it
later in detail, we'll show you the link.
So, then what we're doing is we're just using
to get video Entry method here, passing in
just the string that represents the videoID
and this obviously was the entry event. And
next thing we're doing is like Jeff mentioned,
we're creating our own JSON here, this is
very simple to do and PHP just create basically
create an empty array and then you use the
JSON encode function. So, in this array I've
skipped a bunch of the code but we're just
actually getting the relevant information
that we care about so we get the ID, we get
the title and so on. All these stuff that
we want to display in our front-end. All of
these methods are basically getVideo X so
there's a ton of method inside the video entry
object that you can use to access the metadata,
whether the video is private all this kind
of stuff. And then, you know, some skipping
a little bit of stuff and then of course we
want to handle any kind of exceptions that
may happen. This is how you would do this
with our PHP client library, so you want to
catch an HTTP exemption, get their response
and then get the status and that will actually
tell you, the actual HTTP error message that--actually
that's the error code, I'm sorry, you can
also get this string of the message. And then
we check on that code if, you know, if it's
a 500 error or any other error we just say,
"video is not available." The reason why we
were doing this is because we want to pass
into our JSON feed some kind of string that
we can interpret in JQuery so we can print
out a useful error message here instead of
just sort of an empty object. And that's basically
it for how this application works out. The
code is on GoogleCodeSamples.com you can just
go to the PHP tab and find it there. So, next
we're go on to part two, talk about scaling,
so I'll hand it over to Jeff.
>> FISHER: okay, so we've been through the
basics of how you can build this app and certainly
it's not too hard with out client library.
But what happens if you have a million users
or what happens if you have your own friend
graph or terror of terrors, what happen if
you have million users and your own friend
graph. Well, are you out of luck? Well, no,
so we do actually have a solution for this
that we are announcing today and I think it's
even in a documentation yet, so--and that
SUP. And you know, what's SUP? Well, not much,
I know. But what is SUP? Okay, so, it's the
Simple Update Protocol and the Simple Update
Protocol is the simple and compact 'ping feed'
that web services can produce in order to
alert the consumers of their feeds when a
feed has been updated. So, this is a project
on Google code hosting. It's actually done
by the friend feed guys, who used to be Googlers.
So, and also, I should mention that friend
feed was able to integrate this new thing
that we just launched like, yesterday. So,
they're pretty fast too, or it's just that
easy. So, anyway, SUP is solving this problem.
So, when you have a million users, you know,
how do you get their activity? Well, you could
pull each of their individual one million
activity feeds every few minutes, and see
if they've done anything. That's the one million
HTTP request and are, that most of the users
won't have done anything, especially at like,
five AM. Well, maybe at five AM. But--so wouldn't
it be nice if we had one simple little JSON
feed that just contain the big list of all
the users that actually have done something
in the last five minutes. So, that's exactly
what SUP is. So, if you go ahead and retrieve
your SUP feed which is just gdata.youtube.com/sup,
you get back this thing that's--like I said
JSON and has a really simple on his construction.
So, we have an updated time and that's just
going to tell you when the feed was last refreshed
so you can use that to check if it's changed,
since the last time you pulled it. We have
a sense time, and this identifies when the
activity conveyed in this SUP feed began,
so when the beating of the window that the
SUP feed is for, we have a period which is
in seconds, so 300 seconds; it's five minutes
which is the default. Then we have other periods
and links to those--but most important thing
is we have updates. So, updates is a two [INDISTINCT]
here of two different hash codes. The second
which is the time code hash, which you can
just ignore, it's not that useful, but the
first one is the user hash. The idea here
is that if I know that user hash for the 1
million users that I am interested in, I can
hunt to the SUP feed, see if any of those
1 million hashes are actually in here, and
if so, I can pull for the activity feed for
those users. So pretty straight forward, but
there's an obvious problem here, which is
how, do I know what users these hash codes
correspond to? And to do that, you just actually
retrieve the activity feed for a specific
user, and if you look in the activity feed,
we have this link element that has this link
that points to out SUP feed and inside of
the anchor part of that URL is the hash code.
So the flow here is that someone will go to
your site, and they will authorize you to
use their YouTube account or otherwise, indicate
what their user account is on YouTube. And
then you can pull their activity feed, which
will give you a chance to pre-populate, you
know, all activities they have done in the
past. And at the same time, you can grab their
SUP hash and now you can start monitoring
the SUP feed whenever they have updates. So,
pretty straight forward. So, to demonstrate
that this--again actually works, we built
another activity viewer called the UBER Activity
Viewer, that is going to do the same process
and retrieve user activity. So, here I can--I
suppose to show it. What could go wrong? Okay,
so, here we have a really simple website that
just shows you all the activity for users
that have joined the website, you know, sort
of a friend connect idea, right? So, you just
go in to add yourself, you allow access and
you know, voila, you could add it this background
process that fetch this information from YouTube.
So, as you can see here, the video we favorited
at the beginning has already showed up, although,
but somehow it seemed to be quite displaying,
probably because it's not embeddable. So the
activity that we added earlier actually just
showed up already since our demo-user was
already a member of the site. So, you know,
that's kind of cool. So, here we're pulling
for users and we're not actually retrieving
the activity feeds until we see them in the
SUP feed. And you can try yourself at just
GoogleCodeSample.com/uberviewer, so if you
want to add yourself, then, you know, we can
go back to that later and prove to you that
this actually does work. Although, you will
have to actually add yourself, do something
on YouTube to show up on the SUP feed. So,
how is a sample built? Well, again, we have
your server somewhere in the cloud and now,
instead of just a PHP Website, which we also
have, we have a Java Daemon which is going
to handle all of the SUP business that we
talked about. We also have a MySQL database
that allow this to have some sort of shared
storage, and we have memcached again to store
video metadata for us. So the Java Daemon
goes out into the cloud, fetches our SUP file
from YouTube, process that out and figures
out what YouTube users were interested in.
And then, you know, retrieves those users
activity from the YouTube's API and then put
all that activity into our database. So, pretty
straight forward so far, the PHP Website then
just goes in the database to fetch recent
activity from the site, goes to YouTube API
to fetch additional metadata about all the
videos and what not to have--had activity,
and then stores that metadata in memcached
and once again, has a nice little JSON interface
to our user interface. So, pretty straight
forward, and I want to go into, you know,
each of the parts. First, the Java Daemon
and then the PHP Website. So, why we pick
Java? Well, 'cause it's multi-threaded and
someone already criticized me, "Why don't
you use Python?" Well, I could have used Python
but our client libraries happens to be a little
more friendly in Java, so, I use Java. So,
we have a couple different threads here that
they're going to have their different parts.
And the idea here, why we need threads is
because like I said, if we have a million
users and we're trying to get all of this
activity process in a five-minute window.
You probably want to be doing this, you know,
multiple users at a time and not serially
retrieving each--'cause you know, you know
only 20,000 of those users may have activity,
20,000 requests is still a lot do in five
minutes. So, here's the basic diagram, once
again just, you know, we have the SUP fetcher
thread, that's kind of actually retrieve the
SUP file and parse it for us. And now, we
have the synchronized queue that is going
to get appended to with the user name of what
activity--what users' activity needs to be
updated. And then we have this activity fetcher
thread, which you can configure how many you
need, which I was going to grab out of that
queue and actually pull down the activity
for each of those users, you know, we'll query
and walk on them, so they don't fight over
the same user. And then--so they just go up
to the YouTube API to fetch the activity,
put that in the database and we're done, basically.
Because all the rest is handled by the PHP
Website, which is again very similar to the
PHP Website we saw before. So, what do we
do to start threads? If you knew Java threading,
you pass an object of your creation that implements
random ball to the thread constructor and
you see start. Pretty simple and you do that
again on a loop for all of your activity fetcher
threads. Oh, and all of this code is also
open source, although, we haven't quite posted
it just because of all the hectic-ness on
I/O, but you bother us afterwards, and we'll
then get that posted. So, don't worry about
capping this all down now. So, to close threads,
again, pretty simple, if you remember your
operating systems class how or many years
ago, you interrupt them and then you join
them back to appear in process. Okay, so we
have some--some things that we're using to
share a state. We have this ConfigData object,
which is a read-only object that parses some
configuration files for us, that provides
like the developer key that we're using and
the database password that sort of stuff.
But the interesting stuff is we have some
thread safe objects that Java provides us,
like that blocking queue that I mentioned
earlier, and this concurrent map of user locks.
So, these two things are going to let us have
communication between the threads in a safe
manner, so you don't stamp on each other.
Okay, so the main thread is going to be really
simple. It reads a configuration files into
that object that I have showed earlier. It
sets up some logging with log for J, which
is an awesome logging system for Java. Initializes
the other threads and it listens on a shutdown
port before rejoining them. So, while practicing
this, someone who knows Java a lot better
than me criticize me for not using the shutdown
API in Java, and I couldn't get to wherever
the clips. It was a lot of hassle and control
seat and now it's true, I thought it would,
so I used this and this is a nice hack. You
listen on a local port and when something
tries to make a connection to that port, you
know, that's accept call finally return and
then you quit. So, you can't just tell that
to your server and make a connection and you're
done. So, close your Daemon, however you're
comfortable with, but this is how I did it
for the sample, so it's easy. Okay, so, the
SUP Fetcher Thread, what is the code look
like there? Well, it's going to have to retrieve
users from our database and kind of an implicit
part of this is when the website adds you,
it actually does that step of adding your
token to the database for Java Daemon, record
it in the Java Daemon, but you know, we're
lazy. So, we have the users now, we retrieve
the SUP feed, for each of the user hashes
we find, we add their username to a queue,
and--oh yeah, that's it, right? 'Cause we
also have to deal with the activity fetcher
threads take care of the rest. So, okay, what
does the code look like--first is there's
a really hacky way of scheduling stuff in
Java. I basically compare date object to see
if it's after--the timer suppose to run and
if so, we do all our magic, and if not, we
sleep. If you're really crazy in the Java
threading, you can use something called executors
and you can actually schedule threads to run
at a certain interval. But this is really
easy for samples, so I did that. Using a theme
here, I didn't take the most complex route
on one of these because, you know, I don't
want to make sample code to be relatively
legible. So, to update the time, you know,
you just add so many seconds to a calendar
object and you know, Java is nice like that.
What's really important is already in with
the API, so we get back this user map from
the database just as using JDBC, and you get
back the SUP feed data that was parsing out,
those user hashes and time hashes from the
SUP feed. And then, we do a little Java magic
here, it's kind of nice one [INDISTINCT],
to get rid of all the keys in this users that
we got back that aren't in the SUP feed, and
then we're left with a nice map of all the--usernames
are arranged in [INDISTINCT] we can then append
to the queue. So, we go through the SUP feed,
we parse it out, we got the ones we're interested
in, and then we add those ones to the queue.
Now, we go into the activity threads, so,
we're going to grab usually usernames off
the queue one at a time, acquire a lock on
that username, retrieve the activity feed
for that user, and then add their activity
of course to database, ignore and duplicates,
which is where that ID element that I mentioned
earlier comes into play, and then, we're going
to release the lock and go again get another
username off the queue. So, getting something
off the queue, really easy, and these blocks
so you don't have to worry about sleeping
here, and you may not to worry about sleeping
in this session, no, I was kidding. So, we
also create some sort of new-text lock so
that each of these threads is only going to
retrieve one username at a time, so two threads
aren't retrieving the same activity feed,
including our database. We get the lock, we
acquire it, we get some metadata about the
user, so it's just kind of an aside, it's
important aside. So, I know a thing about
E-tags but they are caching mechanism use
an HTTP to check if you've already retrieved
something or not. So, this is how we check
that we have already--we haven't already retrieved
this particular activity feed insofar that
has changed. That's the last time we pulled
it. We also have the feed updated time, which
is useful because when we get the activity
feed for the user, we can pass that along
and we can actually filter out all the activities
that happened before--I mean, since the last
time we pulled. So, it's just to publish menu
correct parameter it's again, in a documentation.
So, a little efficiency help you out. And
once you have all those activities, you know,
you put them to database, you dig out, the
metadata you care about, store it. And there's
some things to watch out for here, first of
all, you know, if the SUP feed hasn't updated,
which actually check that since time and see
that it has been refreshed. Again, be robust
if the API returns errors, you know, it shouldn't
but sometimes it happens, please handle that
gracefully. And the database connection might
die, so, hang up and you'll be able to hear
of--had allowed experience with JBC in MySQL
but it's kind of pain, yeah, 'cause the connections
will close especially if you have a long running
daemon process like this, after eight hours--but
it's not really closed, 'cause there's no
intrinsic way in the connector to check and
the connections closed outside the performing
query. So, the hack that I used in this, and
you're going to, you know, probably look down
on this, I actually make a really cheap query
on the database before I do my real ones 'cause
I didn't want to bother to rewrite, you know,
some sort of logic where, if the query fails,
they try it again after restarting the connection.
And do what you will. If you use hibernate
in you, you know, like kind of big beard and
you're like, great at Java, we have connection
pulling for you, so you don't have to worry
about this. I mean, I'm sure if you have a
big website, obviously you have solved, you
know, the problems of Java and database is
already--but that's my experience with the
sample. And in the real world--well, in the
real world, we're not going to build a website
that just has all of whoever signs up activity
on the front page from YouTube 'cause that's
kind of silly. It's a great illustrative example,
but what can you actually do that's useful
at this. Well, obviously you can have other
daemon processes that once you get this data,
you can filter it, you can aggregate it, and
can sort it in its different friend circles
and do what you want with it. You can send
notifications to user on their devices, and
again, like I said, you can learn from user
behavior stuff. You know, all the users are
doing on YouTube; you can extrapolate some
interesting things from that information.
So, yeah, like this is just kind of a really
simple sample, to show you that you can get
this information into a database somewhere,
and then you can do whatever you want with
it. And what you know, you chose to do with
it, it's up to you, I'm happy to hear what
your ideas are after this session. So now,
again, talk about the PHP website, we have
Johann back again.
>> HARTMANN: All right, so I'm going to review
the same basic front end with a couple of
the optimizations and then we'll finish up
the talk and open it up to questions after
that. So this time, we're basically doing
the same things that we did before, so we're
getting activities, we're getting metadata
and stuff like that except, we're doing the
log in a little bit differently this time
because, if you remember we're still using
Authsub, but last time because we're making
authenticated request for users friend activity,
we need to have a session token that we can
hold on for the entire time that they are
using the application. So, we continually
make authenticated requests. This time we
really need to authenticate only ones to get
the hash that is in the SUP feed. So, the
way all sub works is when you authenticate
the first time you get a single use token
back. You can use that one, exactly one time.
Normally, you use it to send another request
to get a session token. But this time, we
don't really care about the session token,
so we actually use the single token to get
the hash and then we don't need it anymore.
We write stuff to the database, you know,
we're just using the MySQL extention, PHP,
very simple. And again, we're working with
JSON here, so we're building our own feeds
a little bit in PHP because we want to write,
we want to read JSON feeds back as quick as
possible and write them and send them to our
front-end, the JQuery front-end. We're doing
some paging as well because, you know, there's
really no end to the amount of activity that
could be in this application, so we could
have, you know, thousands of, millions of
users and so, we don't want to actually figure
out how much stuff we have on our database,
so we just use paging and MySQL to just continually
give us a set of results until there's nothing
left. Again we're using memcache for performance
and what we decide to do here is just basically
fetch a page of activities from the database
and then display it and write it to Memcached,
so that when you're paging back and forth,
you know, as you're going back, it's going
to get faster because you can hit memcache
instead of database. So, the way we're doing
authentication here, again is we're getting
the user profile and what you see here is
that, I'm passing in a string default. And
that's a nice feature that we do on the APIs
so, after the user has completed the Authsub
process, you don't actually know their user
name and you know that you have a token for
that user but you don't actually know what
their name is, so we need to get their user
name and, because we don't have it, we can
pass him the string default which will give
you the profile in this case of the currently
authenticated user. So once we have their
profile, you know, we can get their user name
so, this is what we want to write to our database.
And then, we're making an authenticated request
now to that users events feed, and we're stripping,
we're looking for the link that has the updates
real attribute and then we're, you know, skip
the PHP part where we're doing a little bit
string hacking but really we're just stripping
off the last anchor tag here. And this is
how we're getting the hash so, now we have
the two things that we care about, the user
name and the hash and use MySQL to write this
to the database using a prepared statement,
very simple. To get the activity feedback
from the database, what we're doing is we're
doing a multi step process here. So, first
is we're just reading it, passing an integer
for the page that we're currently interested
in. Then we're passing that to an Add Metadata
method. Now, this method is going--look to
that feed, look for the types of activity
that can obviously, either be video or user
related and then it makes separate calls to
the APIs so, if it's a user activity, we fetch
it for user profile and get all the Metadata
that we're interested inn video, we do the
same for video. So, we add all this back and
then just JSON encode it, and now we have
our JSON output that the JQuery front-end
needs. To get the user profile, we're just
making a call here to get user profile, and
again we're using a blank PHP array, in this
case, profile data. To just get the Metadata
that we're interested in, there's a lot of
data, so you can get first name, last name
about me, all this kind of stuff. So, we're
basically storing everything. What I didn't
show on this side is sometimes, you know,
a value could be null, so what we do at the
end before we write the final array that we're
interested in this, we're just looking through
this particular array and stripping out anything
that's null. For video Metadata, it's the
same call that you've seen before as we pass
the video ID, get a video entry back and write
this also to our JSON. We were handling, paging,
it's like I said we memcached each particular
page and then in MySQL, you know, you just
use the offset perimeter that you can see
here. So, we're just passing in. So, basically
what we're doing is reading this, this page
variable and if it's not understandable to
prevent any hacking, of course this is not
a production app but we initialize it to one
if we can understand what it is. And we just
multiply it by the number of items per page
which is a configuration variable of how much
you want to page at a given time. And then
we just pass that to the offset and get our
activities. That basically sums up the application
like I've mentioned, we don't have a code
published yet, but we can get on that, you
know, if you bother us. I want to mention
that we have office hours starting actually
now. They're going to be outside so, you will
have to walk all away around the back section
and you'll find us in the corner. We'll be
there, we'll have some YouTube API engineers,
we'll have our product managers so, any questions
you have about you tube at all and we we're
happy to help you.
>> FISHER: And we're next to the wave guys
so, you know. We've come to see them, you
should at least come to see us too.
>> HARTMANN: Yeah, definitely. Okay, so.
>> FISHER: Oh yeah, so thank you Flicker creative
comments. Ryan will take a picture of the
lion, I'm sorry. See you. Now, we have Q and,
so if you could go up to the mics, we also
have that moderator link that we mentioned
earlier. Does anyone actually follow us into
this? Oh yeah, I actually have questions.
I thought it has got to write my own like,
Jeff why don't you have a haircut? Okay, so
let's see. Is it possible to further... that's
awesome [INDISTINCT] location down there.
Now, so I guess the point itself is that we
can show you all the users on YouTube who
have activity in five minutes and we don't
know which of those people you are interested
in. You know, if there were some way for you
to register with us which those users, I mean,
we could get something like that but that
sounds like, you'll just have, it would just
off load all this burden on to our systems,
but you know its good for you. But it's a
little bit harder convincing the systems guys
to build it. I mean the idea is, this feed
is somewhat large because, you know, there's
a lot of YouTube users out there doing stuff.
But it's only, it's like 700 kilobytes and
its JSON, that part is really fast. I mean,
you can run some bench marks but using like
the Java stuff that we showed, I was able
to [INDISTINCT] the file and like no time
at all basically and hunt through the ones
for that were interesting. Yeah, I must not
sure of the way that we can implement that,
that wouldn't basically be you registering
each user with us somehow and, you know, just
doing, we'll be doing the same thing essentially
just on our servers instead of on yours. Okay
so, is there a way to drive users and application
which uploads videos to become friends?
>> HARTMANN: So, I guess this is more like,
you want to look at your friend graph and
maybe connect users that are doing similar
things, I think, you know, you could do this
obviously by just doing some parsing on your
end and seeing what users you have that are
generally, maybe interested in same video
or rate the same videos highly. And you can
use client libraries to add context so, I
mean, you could make a very easy for a user
to just add somebody as their friend, or subscribe
to a channel that could connect them.
>> FISHER: But you can do through the API,
so you can actually issue a friend request
through the API. And we're working on that
contacts stuff and making that a more robust
to, and like I said it's still an a little
bit of flux because, you know, obviously YouTube
and Google accounts didn't use to be the same
idea but, you know, in the future. Okay so,
can you choose... so you don't share ever
videos that you're watching. Watching is only
if you're part of that experiment with the
bar across the bottom were only your friends
online right there can see what you're watching,
you can share with them only if you turn it
on. Watching a video isn't one of the events.
And right now, I think the only granularity
you have is you can opt out of particular
types of events in our priority settings so,
like, you know, show my video uploads and
my reason of activity is one check box show
my favorites, the videos my favorite is in
another check box, videos I rate, you get
the idea. I don't think there is a way to
explicitly do stuff so, I guess if you question
is, "How can I, what--how can I favorite,
you know some video I don't want my friends
knowing I favorited. That's a little cheeky;
I guess we have to figure that one out. Any
other questions, live questions, complaints?
Oh, sir. Yeah, yeah, then you could build
really easily something in PHP that just rendered
it, I mean, a kind of lied, because we do
have a JSON format right now for our API,
like this is all because JSON, there's also
RSS besides ADAM. But it's kind of ugly in
my opinion. So, if you, if you like JSON,
you see this feed, you're like; Oh.
So, its--it's literally a one to one translation
of the XML but, on like you said there's nothing
like stopping you from rendering a page per
using. Actually, there is a site, I remember,
some one was, this is like, normal user found
a site and all I did was use the API to, you
know, grab their username and then spice some
information about them and then it turn out
in a search somehow or something. And then
like, how is this person have information
about me, and it's like well because you have
this in your public profile. Yeah, right so,
and this wasn't on the microphone so for the
audiences at home, gentleman was just saying
that obviously you can leverage some of our
Google properties and the properties that
Google searched indexing and alert to do a
lot of the stuff that we talked about for
you. Right, so you can integrate with contact,
and calendar and so much, better store, I
hope that someday that can just be part of
YouTube and we don't have to--don't have to
try to work around it too hard. You can log
in with your Google account but it gets tricky.
Its always good states, was a little flow
chart that has like six States in it. Okay,
any other, any other questions, comments?
Okay so, we're going to be outside like we
said like way back in that corner of Mascony
hay and you can just come and ask us, you
know, if you were timid, didn't want to get
recorded on video, whatever. And we'll tell
you about what's wrong with your app or you
know, how to put YouTube into it, whatever.
So, thanks for coming.